some player haters say I'm too scared to
play games and to those people I say go
play bear simulator [ __ ] it's time to
take off the hater blockers
and get into the game
[ __ ] yeah
okay I'm grabbing my guns oh this game
is called Arizona sunshine it's supposed
to be a super scary zombie game sounds
like a game for little girls let's go
okay look at this oh okay watch this oh
oh
here again I'm a little scared but being
scared it's only for losers this is so
cool I am in the desert of Arizona oh my
god there's zombies coming oh my god
it's coming real fast
well the helmets sitting on rocks very
comfy you thought you could get me you
thought you could play I hate too bad
what the [ __ ] is this what what's good
[ __ ] oh this is amazing oh god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god okay
okay uh-huh
he'll back there okay okay oh they got
an Uzi
yeah you like this yeah yeah do you like
that
what sinus mi sir that's my rescue why
did I shoot it then yeah way no matter
what oh I hit my knee
why would you do that
oh my god I'm dying I'm so [ __ ] good
at games fine you know what do you want
to check it out it's your turn to be as
cool as I am I bet you're impressed to
have such a cool boyfriend you thought
that was smarts yet yeah
what would you say you're good at
card cards whatever we could says
because we're playing an automobile of
repetitive breaking gender stereotypes
who better than that I know my car's you
know I I know my stuff all right let's
do that you never know this before right
no yeah what start are you sure it's not
scary ready to pick what I do they touch
okay oh okay do you want to go inside of
the car sweating for a
oh okay Wow you did so well mark you
really have a talent for video games I
mean no please okay kill me
oh man